quel pays est le principal acheteur de
graines de moutarde canadienne les etats
unis le canada exporte en moyenne 115
mille tonnes de moutarde par année plus
de la moitié prend le chemin des états
unis les américains sont
particulièrement friands de graines de
moutarde jaune elles servent à fabriquer
de la mayonnaise des sauces à salade
mais surtout le condiment indissociable
de tous aux dogues digne de ce nom bon
an mal an près de 30000 tonnes de
graines de moutarde sont aussi acheminé
vers le vieux continent les européens
préfèrent de loin la moutarde brune
cette variété sert à fabriquer entre
autres la moutarde de dijon et oui la
plupart des grandes marques de ce
condiment typiquement français
contiennent environ 60% de graines
cultivé au canada et finalement environ
6000 tonnes de moutarde orientale sont
exportée vers l'asie chaque année
principalement vers le japon c'est cette
variété qui possède la saveur la plus
piquante de toutes les graines de
moutarde